so you I hear that you this is really
cool but you're really cool and hot like
you'd work on cars on sets which I heard
that's so cool so you work on old and I
have a Ford Bron for an old one oh way
now I had it restored by someone who
knew what they were doing cuz I'm not
that person but I had it restored like
to its classic like thing the only thing
was the engine I had a CO Coyote 5.0 pit
in because I can't I don't want to work
on an engine girl but you actually work
on them and like restore them yeah so my
best friend's dad who she's actually
here in the audience Jay hi
[Applause]
Jade um her dad builds in the stores
classic Porsches and I bought this Ford
Bronco and I called him up and he's been
like a second dad to me my whole life
and I was like hey I bought this old car
I want to fix it up but I kind of want
to learn how to do it myself that's so
Co and so he let me bring it into the
shop and he just walked me through every
step and we changed the transmissions
and the brakes and the interior and it
it's like incredible how you keep
getting hotter as this conversation goes
on like it's just so cool like I'm like
what I just see you like with the car
and you're just thinking you look awful
but it's like a romcom and you look
beautiful and like it's so cool I love
that you restore cars did you drive in
Australia at all were you brave enough
oh of course okay they actually tested
every single person on the cast if they
could drive a manual but on the opposite
side of the road look what your mother
prepared you for oh and guess what I'm
the only one who could
oh this is a personal shout out to your
mama yes that is so cool yes so Glenn
couldn't do it either cuz I would have
rubbed that he needed well he needed a
couple more lessons ah I love it I love
[Music]
it
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home